cockroaches are nature's most successful
crash-test dummies roaches don't swerve
or slow down when they encounter walls
and it's not because they don't see them
it's because walls are no obstacle these
unstoppable insects hit a wall and keep
on running up they use the force of the
collision to launch themselves
vertically a process that takes just 75
milliseconds now researchers are taking
a page from the cockroach playbook to
create their own wall climbing BOTS most
mobile robots deal with obstacles by
sensing and then dodging around them but
this decision-making process slows them
down and limits their ability to perform
high speed tasks so scientists developed
a sensor 'less cockroach sized robot
with a soft exoskeleton and six legs it
too can shift from horizontal to
vertical movement by simply crashing
into a wall the big secret to its
success is its tiny size a mere 16 grams
as animals increase in size they hit
with more energy during collisions
making them more susceptible to injury
the researchers calculated that only
animals weighing less than one kilogram
would be able to use that cockroaches
head first collision technique for
climbing sad news for real crash-test
dummies who had better just keep
buckling up
[Music]
you
[Music]